[Music]
foreign
I can read you really well I know what
you're thinking right now too what
you thinking about pop times
you like Pop-Tarts is that your favorite
I like little bites all right let's see
I knew what you were thinking I told you
I know what you think what if I told you
I can make some little bites I could
bake them when you just need some fire
right
now you want me to bake some Pop-Tarts
and little bites
[Music]
say goodbye are they real
is it real
surprise I'm scared
don't worry you don't have your watch on
trust me I was looking for your watch
already
here you just have something right here
it's not really bothering me
we're gonna need that in a second we're
gonna do some magic don't worry I won't
make you disappear all right I know you
came with a lot of friends and I want
them to help on the magic too hey boobie
they think I'm gonna make them disappear
too my name is Anna what's your name my
name is booby booby and Uzi yeah
excuse me I really need an extra pair of
hands so can you get closer go ahead and
take one out that one okay and show
everybody the car that you chose
two of diamonds can you sign it for us
okay we're gonna take the two of
diamonds with boobies card and uzi's
signature have you ever done magic never
never I'm gonna teach it to you too so
if you take the card we'll mix it in you
know how to shuffle you guys don't
gamble I mean I I play bucket rat and
you're good yeah you win a lot yeah
what's the biggest you've ever won 500
500 dollars
thousand oh Shadow High Rock Atlantic
City so your card's not on top right not
on bottom it's got to be somewhere in
the middle I need both hands out flat
anyone back there just say stop
stop right here more or less good
this is gonna be my card okay the Ten of
diamonds we give your card The Two Of
Diamonds we're gonna put your hand put
your hand on top like this sandwich his
hands perfect you guys hold hands before
no so there's no way I can get it
between you two strong guys right I'm
gonna be over here with my ten of
diamonds do you remember what your card
was two
so if I have the two of diamonds with
your signature what's in your hand
oh no I don't know
I'm out here nice to meet you nice to
meet you too baby
that's crazy
I like your jewelry which was the most
expensive
um
GIA certified pink diamond so it's like
my most expensive bracelet that I own so
Emma's gonna be looking at your hands
after this so that's why I need everyone
to notice the jewelry make sure it stays
on stays on him the whole time and I
don't make it disappear I promise hold
up both hands flat I'm gonna take your
signed card little Uzi vert on the two
of diamonds we're gonna put about
halfway into the middle of the cards no
sleight of hand making it as fair I'm
gonna put the cards in your hand hold
tight I'm gonna reach you and try to
grab one card from the middle okay ready
one card from the middle don't move what
are the odds you think I got it
I got it I think I got it
you got it but wait wait I could do one
better I can make all the cards in your
hand disappear without me even touching
you
I already did it take a look open my
hands they're gone
[Music]
how'd she do that do you have your phone
my phone yeah hey cap come here
bring your phone
you guys have probably known each other
for a long time right I don't like this
already I've never had anyone so scared
of me within the first five seconds of
me give it up for cup everybody
so it's still locked can you count up
zero to nine out loud zero
one is the first number one
[Music]
I got lucky let's do it again not
backwards nine to zero nah
eight seven six six second number six
do you know his code I think you'd go
for another
is it a one you could have picked anyone
here you could have picked it you could
have been this guy this guy's phone
number we've never met before haven't
set anything up can you confirm
but you seem like you're always on the
go you know in a rush trying to get
somewhere so you want a convenient
passcode but nothing too obvious but I
think you'd go for another six is that
right
do you want me to tell everybody
you could change it later so we go for a
one six one six can I see your finger
Uzi yeah you go for a zero is that right
you're gonna have to change it because
it'll go again there's another zero
[Applause]
so now I can go through your text your
emails there's nothing in here I can't
show everybody right now right
your girlfriend gonna see this she gonna
know your password change it before your
girlfriend season this is the number one
thing ever every girl has asked me to
teach them so you want me to get in your
girl's phone yeah you want me to do that
yeah I'll teach you how to do
today
someone else's phone again I don't want
you to think like movie
he's hiding it from me as if it makes a
difference at this point
go to uh the calculator app I'm going to
ask you guys some questions to test your
connection out in front of everyone here
today how old were you when you met Uzi
23 okay 23 hit multiplies and how many
albums do you have out
three hold the phone for me this is his
phone again so I want you guys to know
that how much does the bracelet cost
this one yeah
just three hundred dollars yeah show the
camera 300 000 okay big number how much
money do you have in your bank account
yeah put the number in you don't you
don't even show me I don't want you to
can I show you you show me
with all the zeros
oh right now right now you check it all
the time that's the number I just came
back from Europe
what does that mean it's supposed to be
more than that I spend too much money oh
this is after it's not as crazy as y'all
think press equals for us hold on to it
we got a random number I don't want to
know what it is we added divide
subtracted multiply everything right
it's kind of a weird number there's like
six digits hundreds of thousands or
seven digits seven just give me the
first number that it starts with seven
seven seven digits seven numbers first
number starts with seven
million three hundred and eleven
thousand is that right three hundred
eleven thousand wait three hundred
eleven thousand nine hundred
ninety five show everybody is that
correct so that's so weird because does
that number mean anything to you yeah
yeah because that's a number but it can
also look like a date what date is this
you were born on July 31st 1995.
oh
because you're a Leo like me I'm a Leo
obviously oh yeah you crazy
we're all crazy give it up for Jordan hi
I'm Anna nice to meet you I think we've
all been waiting for you how do you know
Uzi it's my friend a long time long time
it's so crazy look check this out
do you like magic you don't like magic
you can see all the cards are different
do you want to shuffle them
you you play cars
you play Baccarat too you're gonna hold
on to the cards because Jordan is gonna
do the magic okay I'm gonna give all the
power to Jordan in the deck there are
red cards and black cards which one do
you want us to take out all right do you
want to get rid of the the hearts or the
diamonds
get rid of them we're taking them out so
that leaves us with uh the diamonds so
imagine in a deck you're holding all the
diamond cards okay you like diamonds as
we know there are numbers and letters
which one are we taking out the letters
which letters Jack Queen King James
Kings Jordan do the magical snap the
magician wave whatever you want to do
check it out top card jump to the top
[Music]
I don't know